and finally new rule someone has to tell
me how the world can be so blind while
conservatives here remain apoplectic
about Mexicans crossing the Rio Grande
and Europe freaks out about Syrian
refugees flooding in from the Middle
East no one is paying attention to the
ethnic group it's taking over this
country while we blithely do nothing
[ __ ] Australians
is anybody here in the audience tonight
from here in LA okay then it can't just
be me who is noticed that every single
bartender in this town is suddenly some
six foot four Australian dude with a
great personality who's generous with
the free drinks and we're just letting
it happen wake up people you cannot
swing a dead wallaby these days without
hitting an Australian and it's not just
the bartenders Australians now make up
30% of America's surfing instructors at
an alarming 65 percent of our ski bums
ladies and gentlemen Australia is not
sending us its best people they're
bringing drugs yes enough for everybody
but still they're rapists okay not
rapists but they do a lot of [ __ ] and
I assume some of good people now how do
astray Lian's get here no one really
knows
some say the jet stream carries them
over but we do know this you meet one
and have a few beers next thing you know
he's sleeping on your couch borrowing
your car and [ __ ] your girlfriend and
somehow you're okay with it
it's like getting a golden retriever if
golden retrievers [ __ ] your girlfriend
did you know that in the whole history
of the world there are only four
inventions Australians claim the
disposable syringe the long wearing
contact lens aspirin and penicillin all
created so they could party longer
we used to think oh Sh ins could protect
us because oceans were full of sharks
and sharks eat a lot of Australians but
now sharks are endangered there just
aren't enough of them anymore and there
are too many Hemsworth's does anyone
remember what American movies were cast
with American actors that seems like a
long time ago yeah have we become so
weak and a feat that no defense is
mounted against it Aussie forward that
flawlessly mimics our American accent
and then takes jobs that rightfully
belong to Billy Bob Thornton
because America really needs Simon Baker
when Patrick Dempsey is sitting by the
phone now I partly blame myself first
the Australians came for parts and our
cop movies but I wasn't an actor so I
didn't speak out then they came for our
action movie blockbusters but I wasn't a
soulless studio chief so I didn't speak
out then they came for the Tony Awards
but I'm not gay so I didn't speak out
but I'm speaking now and though you
cannot build a wall on the ocean you can
build a reef and I will build the
greatest reef the world has ever seen a
Great Barrier Reef if you will and I
will make Mel Gibson pay for it
would work no do I care no because I
don't really hate Australians but I'm an
American and it's in our tradition to
hate someone and blame them for all our
problems in the mid 19th century it was
my people
the Irish everyone hated then it was the
Chinese the Italians the Mexicans the
Jews the Swedes the Japanese the
Russians and now the Mexicans again if
Donald Trump really wanted to make
America great again
he wouldn't build a wall he built a
mirror then maybe we would see that no
one can actually take a job someone has
to give it to them we could end our
illegals problem tomorrow if we decided
to stop hiring them but no we talk of
walls to protect us from people so
dangerous that we can't stop ourselves
from paying them to raise our children
as Sarah Palin says you want to be in
America when you're here let's speak
American which begs the question why are
the people who demand that everyone
speak English always the ones who can't
speak English
you